un lendemain de second tour difficile
pour jean yves caullet alors qu'il
bénéficiait de trois mille voix d'avancé
sur son adversaire andré villiers au
soir du premier tour le député sortant
est finalement battu
une défaite que le maire d'avallon met
sur le compte d'une mécanique de report
des voix très politique
les candidats de gauche france insoumise
et autres n'ont pas reporter leurs
suffrages sur ma candidature ce que je
peux comprendre et les électeurs qui
avaient voté front national notamment en
ruralité se sont massivement reportés
sur la candidature d'andré villiers ce
que je comprends moi mais ce dont je
prends acte
un report de voix écrasant en faveur
d'andré villiers entre le premier et le
second tour le président du conseil
départemental a engrangé 7600 voix
supplémentaires contre 2200 pour le
député sortant
certains évoquent une démobilisation du
camp de jean yves caullet je connais des
amis ou à compacter voter qu avez-vous
été collée au premier tour du château
sont pas déplacés pourquoi est ce que je
pensais que c'était gagner tout
simplement
pour d'autres le vote andré villiers
était avant tout un vote de rejet
moi je pense que beaucoup de gens ont
fait comme moi ils n'ont pas voulu voter
pour le candidat en marche pour pas lui
donner trop grande majorité pense que le
fait d'avoir changé de bord en quelque
sorte ne lui a pas ne lui a pas fait que
des amis
moi je peux vous dire que j'ai voté
front national au premier tour et andré
villiers au deuxième tour mais pas par
conviction uniquement pour dégager le le
candidat en marche surtout qu'en plus
c'est un ancien socialiste donc j'en
voulais pas de toute façon une défaite
qui assombrit l'avenir politique de jean
yves caullet le maire d'avalon ne
devrait pas briller de nouveau mandat
aux prochaines élections municipales